we have 15 days left until election day
and huge number of Voters across the
country have already cast their ballots
some of them in the Phoenix area say
that people with guns and wearing
tactical gear approach them at the
ballot drop location others said they
were followed after voting Arizona is
one of many states where Republicans who
question the fairness of the last
election are on the ballot Nancy Cortez
is at the White House tracking the early
voting numbers Nancy good morning
good morning Nate and now early voting
is underway in 34 states and the
District of Columbia more than seven and
a half million people have already voted
either in person or by mail in some
cases smashing records that were set
during the presidential election of
2020.
in Georgia this weekend more than 80
thousand voters showed up on one day
alone a 159 percent increase from the
same day of early voting four years ago
no lag just present my ID they process
straight to the machines and out similar
reports are coming in from Key States
like North Carolina and Florida
Democrats who typically have an edge in
early voting have been urging supporters
to get to the polls now I am worried
about the level of uh voter turnout
among young people and working people
who will be voting Democratic CBS News
has confirmed that behind the scenes
former president Trump has been
encouraging GOP lawmakers in
Pennsylvania to repeal act 77 which
allows all voters in the state to cast
ballots by mail publicly Republicans
spent Sunday hammering President Biden
on high inflation his policies have made
our economy worse we've brought in over
four trillion dollars into the Federal
government's conference last year we
spent nearly seven that is literally
what causes inflation the fight is not
about inflation it's about the cost of
living and if you look at what we have
done to bring down the cost of
prescription drugs to bring down the
cost of of energy that has been opposed
every step of the way by the Republicans
in Arizona election officials are
concerned about possible voter
intimidation in the city of Mesa voters
say armed individuals dressed in
tactical gear set up Friday near a
ballot Dropbox last week voters were
allegedly approached and followed the
justice department in the past has
considered things like
videotaping voters
um taking photographs of Voters as
they're trying to vote
um following them as intimidating
behaviors
meantime a Florida judge has dismissed a
case against a man who was arrested by
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis election
police unit back in August this man was
one of nearly two dozen people who were
issued a voter ID card but then later
arrested and accused of falsely voting
as a felon who was not eligible this
case was tossed because the judge said
prosecutors didn't have jurisdiction in
the case an appeal is expected but this
could set a precedent Gail for more
cases to come
yeah many were surprised by that arrest
in the first place thank you very much
Nancy good to have the update there